within the caldera of the ominous mount
gelmere sits a manner whose very
existence offends the golden order
where all forms of blasphemy exist
where all within challenge the very gods
themselves
and in the center of it all
sets the great serpent
the lord of blasphemy
the demigod praetor reichard
in his youth reichardt had always been
ambitious but alongside this ambition he
was honorable chivalrous and loved
he was one of the demigod sons of
radigan of the golden order and ranala
of the full moon
his lineage alone would provide him with
a wealth of knowledge and reach
it would set his sights and home on the
volcano mount gelmir and there he would
build his volcano manor
when godfrey was hounded from the lands
between he alongside his siblings would
answer the call of queen america
and become one of the demigods that
served the golden order he would become
a justiciar receiving the title of
prator
he would be one who administrates the
law and he would hire inquisitors in
order to root out heresy
despite his position and duties though
his curious mind would wander to things
even beyond the purview of the golden
order or the teachings of raya lucaria
he was naturally adept in sorceries as
the son of a great mage like granala and
with his knowledge he would bring back
ancient hexes like magma sorceries for
practical use as new sorceries expanding
the ever-growing arsenal of raya lacaria
he would travel to foreign lands in
search of people and beauty he would
even find his consort lady tanith when
she was a dancer in a foreign land and
she would be his most loyal follower he
would be part of the construction of
machinery that incorporates
teleportation magic though it is unknown
what they were meant to be used for they
would turn into horrors of the
battlefields known as the abductor
virgins
and like his brother radon he would be
admired for his heroic aspirations
but all that would change when a dark
plot was hatched perhaps it was due to
his love for his sister or his openness
to change
but he would conspire with ronnie the
witch
to orchestrate the knight of the black
knives
rani had plotted to steal a fragment of
the rune of death and use its power
but she wasn't sure what move the death
of the demigods would make and requested
the assistance of reichard using a
combination of his inventive mind and
rani's fearsome right of sorcery they
would create the blasphemous claw in
order to level the playing field and
possibly allow reichard to stand
toe-to-toe against malika the black
blade fortunately for reichard this
battle would never come to pass
the night of the black knives was
successful and god when the golden was
slain
the elden ring was shattered and the
shattering had begun
most of the demigods would move to claim
a great rune during the shattering as
did reichhardt and like many of the
demigods he would seek to claim more
power with his great rune
but in his quest to do so his
open-mindedness would lead him towards
the path of blasphemy
the volcano manor his home would be a
breeding ground of blasphemous rituals
heretical powers and recusants
the honorable praetor himself would come
to embrace the power of a serpent god
possibly named eagley
and he would be known as the lord of
blasphemy
it was due to this that even the royal
capital of liendell in the altus plateau
the realm of the earth tree would come
to wage war in mount gelmere sir gideon
ofner would mention this battle to be
the most appalling battle in the
shattering
the battles would be terrible due to the
unpredictable nature of the blasphemous
powers
the loyal soldiers of the earth tree
would fight tooth and nail and would
sustain heavy losses as they attempted
to take mount gelmere inch by inch
towards the volcano manor
they would lead a two-pronged assault
where the bulk of their army would take
a direct assault on the manor but there
would be heavy resistance
and the other would trek to the
mountaintop both groups however would be
met with horrors like the abductor
virgins which we'll talk about in a bit
marionette soldiers
finger creepers demi humans
grafted scions and all forms of
blasphemous enemies
and those who survived the long trek
would be met with nothing but the
madness of the flame of frenzy
overall the army of landel wouldn't even
be able to approach the volcano manor
reichard's welcoming of this blasphemous
powers would lead him to be reviled not
only by the golden order but even by his
own men
only those who truly walk the path of
blasphemy those who completely despise
the golden order and the gods would come
under his banner
the first of these would be the
inquisitors who had once served reichard
long before these inquisitors already
had a taste of blood and torture even
before the fall of their lord and his
fall would only strengthen these desires
we only truthfully meet one the
inquisitor giza who still brandishes a
unique weapon now fitted on the abductor
virgins
he invades us when we enter the second
floor of the manor possibly a test of
our strength or more likely to end us
before we can bring harm to their lord
the inquisitors would root out all who
believed in the golden order within the
volcano manor and beyond the facade of
the manor within the caldera of mount
gelmere the truth of the manner would be
revealed and the prison town would be
established
the town itself is a horrid site half of
which is already sinking into the lava
it's filled with diseased and tortured
people
the streets itself littered with corpses
being eaten away by dogs
within its buildings you would find
tortured commoners hiding away from the
horrors of the town
you would even come to find the earth
tree seal in one of the prisons within
the town
indicating that those imprisoned and
tortured here were loyal to the earth
tree
many of these people could have been
former followers of reichard who had
come to live within the manor before its
turn to blasphemy but many more may have
been abducted by the monstrosity that is
the abductor virgins these horrors had
their arms fitted with the weaponry of
the inquisitors and their structure was
built with the iconographies of the
serpent god
even the arms that grab you are serpents
it's possible that these transformation
is what led to most of them losing their
teleportation abilities
these monstrosities would be horror on
the battlefield and those caught within
it would be more lucky to die within
than be brought back to the manor
beyond this prison town would probably
be the most eerily named part of the
manor the guest hall
but within you would not find any guests
but rather tortured albinorics
these guests are not only tortured for
the pleasure of the torturers but also
for blasphemous experiments
their skin would be used by the other
heretics and they would be tortured
further to lead them into madness
there would be no escape for the
horrible fate of all these albinorics
after this torturous area though comes a
place of worship
a temple dedicated to the serpent god
but before we head above to the temple
let us go down and explore what is under
it
if you go below the temple you might
come upon a magma worm hidden within the
lava
this was something i brought up before
in a community post and most people
chalked it up to being a native creature
within the volcano in truth though it
too is a creature of blasphemous origins
magma worms are what those who covet the
power of dragons turn into should they
partake in dragon communion too much
they would become magma worms as such it
is no wonder that we would find two of
them within mount gelmere as they too
are welcomed within the blasphemous
mountain
we even find some warrior jars here
possibly taking the remains of the
warriors who once fought for reichard
now let us move to the top of the
elevator where we are greeted by a
traitorous fire monk
who now worships the black flame instead
of the flame of ruin
after taking care of him we come upon
the temple of eagley
before we talk about what we find within
though let's talk a bit about the
serpent iconography all around this
temple
we see serpents with wings and talons
now this could represent a lot of real
world references but for now let's not
go there and stick to what we know in
game lore wise this to me speaks of the
crucible
a time when all manner of creatures were
blended into uniquely divine creatures
that share traits from multiple beings
this becomes more evident because of
what we find within the temple itself
we find another of one of the most
heretical factions in the lands between
the god skin apostles and one of their
most elite and ancient members a god
skin noble we touched on this on our
previous video about the black flames so
i'll only make a brief explanation on
them the god skin nobles themselves are
relics of the age of the crucible
beings who embody the aspects of other
creatures they would come to the manor
for reasons we wouldn't really know but
something that we can speculate on a
likely scenario would be one where they
would have an accord with the
blasphemous lord for a supply of skin
maybe even specifically god's skin from
the snake god
the snake skin we find within the temple
of eagle looks like the discarded skin
of a great serpent but as we will later
find it seems small in comparison to
what reichardt had become
its skin was probably used by the god
skins and in exchange they would impart
knowledge about the gods the flames and
most importantly the crucible
i believe the knowledge that the
godskins would impart would allow
reichard to create creatures and beings
of his likeness
but before we talk about what those
creatures are let's take a brief moment
to talk about the great serpent's skin
we find here i offer two possible
speculations for what this is
first is that it may be the discarded
skin of reichhard or it may even be
another great serpent that was used
within the horrific ritual that bore the
man-serpents
it could even be both
in any case i leave that up to your
imagination for below the great
serpent's skin on an altar we find the
serpent's a minion which seems to be the
catalyst and origin of the man snakes
the next part of our leisurely tour of
blasphemy
we have seen the man snakes before in
the prison town and if you've been
visiting raya every chance you get you
may have caught her in her snake form
after you tell her about the secrets of
the volcano manor she would eventually
tell us about what she discovered about
her true origins
about the lies that she was told about
being the daughter of a great king
in truth she was the product of a
horrible ritual that combines man and
serpent
one that shouldn't exist within this
world
i'm afraid there is something i must
tell you
i was an unwanted child
born not of grace
but of a hideous
ritual
something that can never be accepted
not by men
nor serpents
even lady tanith shouldn't accept me
this could be the knowledge reichard
sought from the god-skin apostles
knowledge of the crucible for while
tanet's night is a crucible night they
merely call upon the power of the
crucible through incantations while the
god-skinned nobles themselves embody the
inhuman physiology of the crucible
this realization is too much for the
likes of raya
and from here you could either give her
the tonic of forgetfulness or you could
free her from the curse she bears and
take her life either way the decision is
yours to make
should you slay her though you would
receive a talisman known as dedekar's
woe and i believe it would be dedica who
would be the true mother of all the
man-serpents the ritual itself would be
one i can only imagine to be truly
heretical and in the end it would be
from her body that the arminian would be
carved out from
going further into the manor the
man-serpents inhabit this next area
but before we can even get there we come
across commoners who are infused with
poison
these commoners may have been used as
feed by the man-serpents as their fangs
contain poison they are slowly dying
through the poison
unable to leave as there is truly
nowhere else to go even jumping into the
lava would be met with the serpent's
fangs
instead they would be forced to worship
the man serpents while cowering in fear
for their life
passing through the secret areas within
the manor we come upon a room that may
be lady tanets the room itself clearly
depicts her infatuation with the lord of
blasphemy
let us take this moment to speak about
her
as mentioned previously reichard would
find lady tanith in a foreign land and
there he would take her as concert due
to her magnificence
she would become his most loyal follower
during the battle for mount gelmere
reichard's men would leave him as they
could not abide the path of the
blasphemous but the loyal lady tanith
would not leave his side no matter how
low he would fall
she would even take charge of the
operations of the recusants
the recusants are the tarnished hunters
who abide by the path of blasphemy their
very code would be that the strong take
the strong take
such is our code
the most fearsome recusant we meet
within the manner is bernal one who is
worthy enough to truly become a lord
though most of the recruits would be
questionable at best if you recall the
alice from the round table hold when you
first arrived there he was looking for
his assistant lanya
but she would be killed by a recusant
and the alice who is from the famed
house of hoslow would vow revenge for
her death luckily for him his famed
house would be enough for him to receive
an invitation to the recusants and to
the volcano manor
after his arrival however we find him
backing away from his vow
as he can see the true measure of the
recusants one a coward like him would
never be able to match
he would simply cower within the drawing
room of the volcano manor unable to make
his move until ultimately giving up and
leaving the manor
another of their questionable recruits
is patches the untethered
i have no idea how this snake got an
invitation to the manor but patches
joined the volcano manor not for the
strength they exude nor for the path
they walk
but for the beauty and admiration for
lady tanith
though this admiration would never be
returned
the recusants are essentially assassins
they hunt famed and powerful tarnished
and take the power they possess
be it items weapons or fame
targets are assigned through a letter
and recusants may even work together in
order to bring down stronger foe
they would fell even the wolf of the
round table hold the great horn targoth
who had saved countless other tarnished
and even the famed juno hoslo of house
hostle
out of all the heretics of the volcano
manor true recusants are by far the most
dangerous members but even them pale in
comparison to the lord of the volcano
manor the lord who would devour all the
gods prato reichard the lord of
blasphemy
the once honorable prater is now but a
face of the great serpent that devoured
him his grotesque form encapsulates the
path of blasphemy that he took his
heroic aspirations now replaced by greed
and power no longer does he seek
knowledge to benefit his house and his
family but now only for the power it can
give
no longer does he seek to better the
lives of his people now he only sees
them as sustenance for his evolution
no longer does he see the beauty in
things he only sees the power that he
wishes to devour
though his body is one with the serpent
he lives as a separate being to it
as even after killing the serpent itself
reichardt is still able to control the
body and use it
the body of the serpent itself is broken
and the souls of the champions he had
eaten are trapped within
only the serpent hunter can bring down
this being of pure heresy
and as the code of the recusant state
the strong take we would fell the great
serpent slicing its body into pieces
with the serpent hunter and from its
corpse we would take its power
within the chamber of the lord we would
find a curious item as well an armor
piece that belongs to the agents of sir
gideon ofnir
either he was spying on reichhardt or he
too was interested in the blasphemous
knowledge
upon our triumphant return to the manor
we would announce our success in killing
reichhard
none of the recusants would admonish our
actions for we simply followed the code
the volcano manor would collapse and
their recusants would go their own ways
i believe it is at this moment that
bernal would come across the blasphemous
claw and would make his way to attempt
to challenge
malaketh the black blade
lady taneth would visit her lord and if
you make our way there once again we
would find her eating away at the corpse
of reichhard
the corpse itself seemingly still alive
taneth wants her lord to find perch
within her so that they may continue
their path to slay the gods
you can slay tanith here to possibly
prevent that future from happening
her knight would arrive late to save her
and upon defeating him this should be
the end of the blasphemous lord
but as he said at the moment of his
defeat
shall
you